>> WE HAVE EXCITING NEWS HERE,
OUR CHIEF METEOROLOGIST, AN
OFFICIAL JUDGE, THE FAMOUS HOT
DOG EATING CONTEST.
SO HOW DID YOU GET THIS GIG, I
AM SO JEALOUS?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON'T KNOW, BUT
WHAT AN HONOR.
I SAID TO MY HUSBAND THAT THEY
WANT ME TO BE AN OFFICIAL JUDGE
ON THE FOURTH OF JULY TO JUDGE
THE HISTORIC HOT DOG EATING
CONTEST AND JOEY CHESTNUT WILL
BE BACK.
SEVENTY-SIX HOTDOGS, 10 MINUTES.
SO I GET TO BE ONE OF THE
ESTEEMED JUDGES THAT GETS TO
COUNT.
WE HAVE COMPETITION BETWEEN THE
WOMEN AS WELL, ALSO RAINING
CHAMPIONSHIP WINNER, SHE WAS
PREGNANT LESTER SO SHE COULD NOT
COMPETE, BUT WHAT AN HONOR.
ONE OF THE JUDGES PASSED OUT
APPARENTLY.
>> STAY UPRIGHT, ALSO IT IS GOOD
TO SEE SOMEONE TOOK A YEAR OFF.
SO WHAT DO YOU SEE YOUR ROLE AS
BEING, ARE YOU GOING TO
DISQUALIFY PEOPLE?
>> THERE ARE RED CARDS.
YOU GET A RED CARD IF YOU REJECT
THE HOT DOG, THAT'S A POLITE WAY
OF SAYING IT, THAT YOU DON'T
THROW IT UP.
SO YOU CAN GET DISQUALIFIED.
YOU WILL GET DISQUALIFIED.
MESSY EATING IS A YELLOW CARD.
AND I AM JUST EXCITED ABOUT IT,
MY FAMILY IS COMING IN MY KIDS
AND MY HUSBAND, MY NIECE AND MY
NEPHEW.
THIS IS AN HONOR.
DO WE KNOW ANYONE THAT HAS EVER
HAD THIS KIND OF HONOR?
>> THE OFFICIALS HAVE SAID THAT
NO, NO ONE HAS EVER HAD THIS
HONOR BEFORE.
ONLY 45 SECONDS TO ANSWER.
IT IS THE HOT DOG A SANDWICH?
>> OH, MY GOODNESS, I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO GO THERE.
THAT WILL REQUIRE MORE THAN 45
SECONDS, IT IS NOT A SANDWICH.
>> OKAY, I ASKED YOU A QUESTION
AND YOU CAN'T SAY YOU CAN'T
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
[LAUGHTER]
>> ON THE JUDGE, I JUDGE MYSELF.
>> I'M GOING TO BE STARTING AT
5:00 A.M. ONWARD AND THEN THE
ACTUAL COMPETITION STARTS AT
10:00 A.M., 10 MINUTES FOR THE
BOYS, 10 MINUTES FOR THE GIRLS
AND THERE WILL BE A CHAMPION AND
I WILL BE AN OFFICIAL JUDGE.
>> ANNA, I'VE KNOWN YOU FOR A
LONG TIME.
I AM SO HAPPY F